[Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  uh  we'll do this together everyone i  promise you i won't fail  father i hope i can live up to your name  [Music]  i've been through many hardships to be  at your side my failures will not be  repeated a second time  [Music]  what would you have me do i always  complete the tasks i'm given  though to be honest i'm not one for  following orders to the letter  hello chin's my name you need me and my  [Music]  sharpshooters  the honor of the reugen clan falls on my  shoulders  i am glad to join you in this fight  oh i'm used to doing all sorts of jobs  we all have to muck in where i come from  what do you need  sometimes great things come in tiny  packages  my you name is me  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  you